for bus Caesar experience with text but
he will design recommends using a
dynamic time instead of smaller type
sizes or truncating larger size text we
made this much easier to implement with
the introduction of text view auto
sizing let's see how to use it to
customize it and what caveats you need
to be aware of with Android Oh in
jetpack text view gain the new property
Auto size text type which allows you to
optimize the text size when were human
dynamic content to enable auto sizing
set auto size text type to uniform this
scales text uniformly on horizontal and
vertical axes ignoring the text size
attribute when using jetpack make sure
you use the app namespace note that you
should not use wrap content for layout
width or layout height protects you set
auto size since well it may produce
unexpected results instead use match
parent or a fixed size turn off auto
sizing by selecting none
instead of uniform you can also use auto
size programmatically like this if you
want to customize your text view more we
have some extra attributes for you auto
size min and Max text size and step
granularity the text view will scale
uniformly in the range between the
minimum and the maximum size in
increments of step granularity if you
don't set these properties but if all
values will be used programmatically
these values can be set via this method
to have more control over the final size
if for example your app needs to comply
with specific text sizes I invite lines
you can provide a list of sizes and it
will use the largest one that fits
create an array with the sizes in your
resources and then set the auto size
preset sizes attribute in XML or do this
in code by providing an array of preset
sizes and their unit using dynamic
stylus for text views makes your app
more interesting and helps your users
decode content quickly so start using
the auto size property
genetics affect and improve your years
or experience